So the history
of MDMA begins in 1912,
when it was first synthesized
and patented by Merck,
but they didn't do
anything at all until 1927.
And Merck did some preclinical
studies in animals,
and found nothing of interest
and they decided to just
shelve the compound.
This is around the time
their patent is gonna expire.
The next we know of MDMA is
the army chemical warfare
service, MK-Ultra,
looking for mind control drugs,
and then Sasha Shulgin, who
was an incredible chemist,
he started looking for new
drugs for psychotherapy
and for personal growth and spirituality.
And he re-synthesized MDMA,
experimented with it on himself,
and felt that it had incredible
potential for therapy.
And so he gave it to Leo
Zeff, who was the leader
of the Underground Psychedelic
Psychotherapy community.
From the middle '70s to the early '80s,
roughly half a million
doses of MDMA were used
in therapeutic growth settings,
mostly by people that Leo had trained,
and it was found to be useful
in a wide variety of conditions.
But it leaked out of that
community, became sold as Ecstasy,
and this was at the time of
Nancy Reagan and "Just Say No",
and the rise of the drug war again,
and so it was clear that it was doomed.
So this was an incredible
opportunity to gather support
to prepare for the defense of MDMA
once the Drug Enforcement
Administration finally decided
to move against it.
It was in Dallas at the Starck Club
where Ecstasy really became popular,
MDMA became popular as Ecstasy
in a dance club setting.
George Bush, all sorts of
people participated here,
and this is what attracted
the attention of the DEA.
So in the summer of '84,
DEA moved to put MDMA in Schedule I.
They only knew about it as a party drug,
they didn't know about
it as a therapy drug.
So in '86, I started MAPS as a non-profit.
MAPS is the Multidisciplinary Association
for Psychedelic Studies.
MDMA is the most gentle of
the all the psychedelics,
that's why I felt it
would be the first one
to make it through the system.